[Music]
a pivotal white house meeting of three
world leaders to discuss the
applications of finland and sweden to
join nato
today i am proud to welcome
and offer the strong support of the
united states
for the applications of two great
democracies
and two close highly capable partners
to join the strongest
most powerful defensive alliance in the
history of the world finland and sweden
have remained out of the north atlantic
treaty organization preferring
neutrality for in the case of finland
decades and sweden for centuries
russia's invasion of ukraine changed
that pushing sweden and finland to side
with nato and oppose vladimir putin's
war and support ukraine the situation in
ukraine
reminds us of the darkest days of
european history
together we have responded forcefully to
russia's aggression
and provided unprecedented support to
ukraine
we have not flinched
30 nato members must approve the
membership bids but turkey is opposed
accusing the nations of harboring and
financing groups turkey deems terrorists
nato's enlargement would be meaningful
for us as long as our sensitivities are
respected giving all kinds of support to
the pkk and the ypg terrorist
organization and asking us for support
for nato membership amounts to say the
least to inconsistency
there are concerns the president of
finland did not dismiss
we take terrorism seriously we condemn
terrorism in all its forms
and we are actively engaged in combating
it
we are open to discussing all the
concerns
turkey may have
concerning
our membership in an open and
constructive
manner the white house says it's
confident it can overcome turkey's
reservations to the nato applications
for sweden and finland but it won't say
how still this is just the first hurdle
even if turkey approves the first stage
of the applications there are still
opportunities for it to veto the process
in the future
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house